I heard some people laughing at some
dumb [ __ ] parts in this movie which
tells me one of two things one either
I've become a humorless boring [ __ ]
my possible I'm not going to rule it out
or two this movies actually as stupid as
I think it is and if people actually
like it we have about 25 years before we
are wiped out like mankind extinct
forever vacation two vacations this in
continuity reboot type thing we're Russ
Griswold the kid from the other vacation
movies he's grown up now and he wants to
take his family to Walley world so it's
a roadtrip movie not gonna lie track
record on road trip movies they're not
that great your life feels like every
time I talk about a roadtrip movie or
I'm reviewing a movie that turns out to
be a roadtrip movie it's [ __ ]
maybe this movie was dead on arrival at
that point but pretty much we have a
roadtrip movie and it's not that good it
sucks first of all the characters in
this movie just frustrate the [ __ ] out
of you you don't relate to any of them
this movie has no heart whatsoever think
about the other vacation movies it's the
Christmas vacation for example because I
love that the Griswolds the family they
were characters they were a family you
related to them so you were rooting for
them and this one I just kind of wanted
all of them to die in a car fire can we
have that happen ed Helmes in the movie
B plays a dumb [ __ ] idiot where you're
like you're just useless dude it'd be a
great side character but it's like the
lead dad in this movie now one of the
sons is a complete wimp the other one
the youngest one is the complete
[ __ ] it was mean-spirited humor with
him I mean not that mean-spirited humor
is always bad I'm just saying if you're
gonna do mean-spirited humor have
opponent have a purpose have the joke
lane so people look oh [ __ ] that was me
but love is so good on this one they're
all singing together and he's always
like picking on the older brother which
is like this ironic thing in the movie
he's just like alright let me try
uh Kevin's a piece of [ __ ] weirdest
things people in the audience were
laughing at that like quite a few people
were just like it was weird man I was
like white that's not funny it's the
weakest joke on earth this is like
someone going on poop there's nothing
there the joke has no backbone to it
it's just like something someone says
and it's not just this family everyone
in the movie is really an idiot Leslie
Mann plays who she always plays so she's
an idiot Chris Hemsworth's an idiot ed
Helmes is an idiot the older sons an
idiot the youngest son is a piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ] he's kind of an idiot if
this movie were a remake of the stupids
it would make sense
it's not so it doesn't christina
applegate I thought she was awesome
chances one segment where she goes and
visits her old sorority and it was
actually pretty cuz she was good at that
point I was like she's gonna be the one
that saves his movie right oh she
doesn't quite save it but she is good in
the movies this movie is just a shitty
roadtrip movie that tries to be a
nostalgia trip for the vacation movies
with nothing that the vacation movies
had to offer really so yeah what I'm
trying to say his vacation is [ __ ]
yeah that's not to say I didn't Ellie's
chuckle in a couple of parts in this
movie this movie had a couple of chuckle
worthy moments for sure doesn't mean
it's good though right guys so vacation
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought because
you didn't listen to my room why didn't
you listen to my review you should all
listen to this review I don't have
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more